is jesus actually god yes that's so heavy let me
pray again father i lord as i deal with this you
talk to me just take me out of the way and just
talk to me let me be possessed by your spirit
in jesus name i pray amen go
to first timothy chapter three
first timothy chapter three i recognize
that young professor right there
do you have first timothy chapter
three do you have verse 16
if you have the king james version read it with
me carefully are we ready let's read and without
controversy great is the mystery of godliness
come on god was manifest in the flesh stop
now stop stop stop thank you for being eager to
read god bless you god was come on manifest in
the flesh that's the great mystery great mystery
but we must understand sufficient because as we
understand it it changes us god was manifest in
the flesh now let's add to that go to matthew 1.
matthew 1
is aaron back there could you
take that picture off please
you can put a q and a one yeah previously
yeah put something like that take off
that ball-headed vegetarian all right
did i say matthew chapter one all right let's read
verse 21 are you there read with me and she shall
bring forth a son come on and thou shall call
his name jesus why for he shall save his people
from their sin from how many sins all they said
not some all now what is his work in verse 21
he saves them from their sin but who is
he go to verse 23 who is this person that
saves them from their sins read for me behold
a virgin shall be with child come on and shall
bring forth a son come on and they shall call
his name immanuel which being interpreted is
god with us now what is the work he does
in verse 21 who is he in verse 23 god
only god can save you it's a it's
a it's an error i see in the church
for those of us who believe some advantages
believe jesus is not equal with the father
only god can save you go to romans chapter 1.
do you have romans 1 16 you don't have it yet is
in the new testament you have it now okay read
with me what does this say for i am not ashamed
of the gospel of christ nice and loud for it is
the power of the angel gabriel unto salvation the
power of god only the power of god can save you
yes christ is god was christ worshipped when he
was on this earth because he was god and man at
the same time i never said christ is the father
but christ is fully god go to hebrews 1. and i'm
glad this question was asked you'd be amazed
what people believe in the adventist church
which is not among the official doctrines
by the way do you have hebrews 1
this is the father speaking to the
son what are my favorite chapters
here's what the father says in verse
8. and what does that read that for me
the throne but of the sun he saith thy throne
o god is forever and ever stop what does the
father call him oh god oh god a scepter of
righteousness is the scepter of thy kingdom
what is the father saying jesus has a kingdom when
you read read microscopically thank you very much
verse 9 thou hast love righteousness and hated
iniquity skipped verse 10 and thou lord in the
beginning has laid the foundation of the earth
and the heavens at the work of thy hand stop
the father says who created heaven and earth come
on who the son read verse 11 they shall perish
but thou remain stop what does that tell you
about jesus and creation they shall perish
creation will do what pass away but thou what
does that mean christ is eternal the father is
proclaiming the eternal nature of jesus they shall
perish but thou reach their remains and they all
shall wax all this as the death of garment huh
but thou are the same and thy years shall not fail
that's eternal christ is an eternal being
now since the father identified christ as god
he called him lord in verse 8. lord god in
verse 8 lord in verse 10 let's go to psalms 90.
we know who the creator is let's go to
psalm 90. somebody say amen for the bible
you have psalm 90 read from verse 1
lord thou has been our dwelling place in all
generations before the mountains were brought
for stop who brought the mountains forth jesus
before the mountains were brought forth however
thou has formed the earth and the world even from
everlasting to everlasting finish it thou art god
jesus is as divine as the father and the
holy spirit is as divine as the father
now they have different functions are you with
me in divinity they're like this in function
they're like that are you with me we have
father son holy spirit equally divine each
one but in function we have father we have
son we have holy spirit go to john 13 16
i'm taking a little while but this is important
pastor and we have from six until the sun sets
i didn't say i'll take all that time i just said
we have it from six until the sun says okay where
did i send you john what chapter 13 what first 16.
now most of the reading is coming from the left
let me hear someone from the right read as
well i just keep me already from the left
but let's all read together are you
with me read with me now verily verily
i say unto you the servant is not
greater than his lord come on neither
he that is sent greater than him that sent him
now we have two people in that verse name them
the servant and the lord who's greater come on
be confident even if you're wrong who's greater
the lord and the lord is the one who does
what he sends now listen to john 17 3.
no you don't have to go there you know it and this
is life eternal that they might know thee the only
true god and jesus christ whom thou has sent
referee john 5 john 17 whom the sent have sent
have sent have sent now it means with respect
to authority who is higher the one who sends
go to john 15. somebody said okay john 15. read
verse 20. are you there what does that say read
for me remember the word that i said unto
you the servant is not greater than his lord
if they have persecuted him they will do what yes
if they did it to me he won't do it to you the
servant is not great the one who sends is greater
than the one who sent him now go to john 14.
let's read verse 28
are you there read for me nice what does it say
you have heard how i said unto you i go to my way
and come again unto you if you love me you will
rejoice because i said what i go unto the father
for my father is greater than i now in what sense
is the father greater in the sense of authority
and responsibility not in the sense of divinity
the father the son and the holy spirit are
fully divine and white calls them the three great
powers of heaven who are working for our salvation
but with authority let me show you again
the authority go to john 14. read verse 26
but the comforter come on which is the holy
ghost whom the father shall sin in my name stop
the comforter the father will send him in my name
the name is the authority of jesus
now go to john 15. read verse 26
oh hold up hold on let's read together
are we ready let's wait what does it say
but when the comforter is come whom i will
send unto you from the father even the spirit
of truth which proceedeth from the father he
shall now jesus says i will send him in verse
26 of chapter 15 jesus said the father will send
him verse 26 john 14. in other words the father
and the son can send the spirit the
spirit doesn't send them anywhere
now when christ was on earth in his humanity
the spirit directed him luke 4 18 the spirit
of the lord is upon me because he has
anointed me to preach yes but as god
he said that what happened at pentecost jesus sent
the spirit to give him thomas jesus is fully god
and if you don't believe that you may have a
nice religious life but you cannot be saved by
someone less than god i say again jesus christ
let me give you one more verse go to isaiah 9.
isaiah 9.
are you there who can guess
what verse i want you to read
who can guess the verse someone who
loves jesus who can guess the verse
6 6 all right are you there six let me pray
again father continue to be with us all as we
listen to your word and try to understand under
the guidance of your spirit in jesus name i pray
amen read with me for unto us a child is given
unto us a child is born unto us a son is given
and the government shall be on his shoulder
and his name shall be called wonderful come on
counselor come on the mighty god stop the mighty
god keep reading the everlasting father the prince
of peace a better translation of everlasting
father is the father of eternity you see eternity
flows from jesus that's a concept we can't
understand because eternity has no end but it
come jesus is the source of eternity so he's the
father the everlasting father made the father of
everlastingness and he's called the mighty
god we need to understand this stupendous fact
that the person in that manger with arms
and legs wriggling in the air helpless
was the one who said let there be
light and he took that step to save us
no one less than christ could have come to
die because he had to give up the life that is
naturally his if the angel gabriel had come to die
he would have been giving up a life that's not his
because he received life from the creator are
you following me the life had to be the life
that naturally belongs to the victim dying
on that cross only christ can fulfill that
no angel could but the angels wanted to come and
die no you can't die for sin the life is not yours
i can die because the life is mine and so i give
it up and i take it back up go to john i keep
saying one more verse go to john 10. i want you to
leave here understanding jesus christ is fully god
don't put your salvation in peril by
believing he's less than god john 10
verse 3 from verse 16 and you found it let me know
read with me and other sheep i have which are not
of this fold them also i must bring and they will
hear my voice and there shall be one fold and one
shepherd keep reading therefore doth my father
love me because i laid on my life that i might
take it again verse 18 no man taketh it from me
stop jesus wasn't killed jesus gave up his life
now you're saying yes because you're nice
but do you understand what i'm saying
jesus gave up his life if he had been killed
it would have been an unwilling sacrifice
are you with me he willingly gave up his life
so he says in verse 18 no man taketh it from me
but i laid down of myself now finish
the verse i have power to lay down
now stop wait wait a minute no
dead person can raise himself
jesus raised himself now the bible says the father
raised him the father the bible says that because
the father told him when to get up but jesus said
destroy this temple and in three days i will rise
if the father had raised him jesus would need an
assistant no christ needs no assistance to save us
so hebrews 1 verse 3 when he had by himself purged
our sins and to purge the sins required the death
and the resurrection are you with me to
purge sins requires death and resurrection
go back to the sanctuary the sinner brought
the lamb the lamb was slain that's the death of
christ the priest is the living christ and he goes
into the temple to apply the blood you must have
death and resurrection to have sins taken care of
jesus christ is fully god somebody say a man for
jesus you